tenemos el número 357 el 3 se encuentra
en el lugar de las centenas así que esto
representa 300 100 200 300 tenemos tres
centenas que es lo que representa este 3
pues se encuentra en el lugar de las
centenas vamos a escribirlo centenas
después tenemos un 5 en el lugar de las
decenas
cinco de las decenas y esto representa
un 50 tenemos uno dos tres cuatro cinco
decenas
y al final tenemos en el lugar de las
unidades 7
esto representa 7 unidades 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
siete unidades ahora a partir de esto
queremos restarle 251 y queremos restar
dos centenas cinco decenas una unidad
pausa en el vídeo y piensen en qué es lo
que va a hacer esto
hagamos el cálculo juntos vamos a
enfocarnos en las unidades
comenzamos con 7 unidades de las 3
centenas 5 decenas y 7 unidades de 150 y
77 unidades a las que les voy a quitar
una unidad
vamos a dibujarlo en otro color quitamos
una unidad la tachamos aquí y nos van a
quedar seis unidades seis unidades vamos
al lugar de las decenas tenemos cinco
decenas a las que les vamos a quitar
cinco decenas así que quitamos una
decena dos decenas tres decenas cuatro
decenas cinco decenas quitamos todas las
escenas así que ahora tenemos cero
decenas y finalmente comenzamos con tres
centenas pero les vamos a quitar dos
centenas vamos a hacer lo quitamos una
centena dos centenas nos quedamos con
esta centena de acá una centena tres
centenas menos dos centenas es igual a
una centena yo espero que esto les dé
una apreciación de lo que ocurre en las
posiciones de valor pueden decir bueno
alineo los números veo las posiciones de
valor y aquí tengo 7 menos 16 55 es cero
3 - 2 es uno pero yo quiero que piensen
que es lo que está sucediendo aquí
estas son 7 unidades menos una unidad
que nos da 6 unidades
estas son cinco decenas menos cinco
decenas no nos va a quedar ninguna
decena y 300 tres grupos de 100 vamos a
quitarles dos grupos de 100 por lo que
nos va a quedar solo un grupo de 100 nos
van a quedar 106 una centena cero
decenas y seis unidades